texans have had enough as the lone star
state begins building border wall
without federal funds the department of
homeland security announces it will
begin filling gaps in the border war
after president biden stopped its
construction
there's enough enough of the open
borders policy enough of the record
spike in violent crime and drug
smuggling that we've seen in border
communities in texas and we're going to
take matters into our own hands
joining me now fox news contributor and
retired acting ice director tom homan
tom thanks so much for being with us
today and i suppose there are two
different issues there one is texans
going ahead building the wall using
their own funds
and the other is dhs apparently seeming
to admit that the walls do work or they
wouldn't be filling in these holes but
let's break those two down what do you
make of texas building its own wall
being forced to build its own wall
i think the government's doing the right
thing for the state of texas i think
he's doing the right thing for the
nation because i've been down the border
numerous times 95 percent of these
people coming across illegally that get
released in the united states aren't
staying in texas they're going to every
city town and state in the nation so
he's doing the right thing and look
every
governor abbott did something that my
administration has refused to do he
looked at the data the data clearly
shows every place they built a border
barrier every place
illegal immigration declined illegal
drug flow
declined lies are saved walls will
funnel the family groups the most
vulnerable the family groups to an area
where border chill will be assured to
arrest them and and take care of them if
there's illnesses walls work and the
bite administrators come out saying
we're going to fix gaps look it's a joke
they'll fix some gas but they're not
going to build miles of wall even though
they got
millions and millions of
wall material sitting there riding on
the ground which they should give to
texas or they should sell to texas and
put it back in the taxpayers coffers
because texas is building in the wall on
texas land and ranchers who donated
lancaster's sickness crisis but let me
say one more thing
a lot of land was seized through eminent
domain to build a wall
and the bite administration has been
clear we're not going to build a wall so
that land
needs to be returned to texas and to the
rangers of texas so the government so
the governor can build even more wall on
that land
yeah it's fascinating to see them step
up and defend their own borders like
that and you have said that every mile
of walls saves lives decreases illegal
immigration um
and so certainly a positive thing there
but i want to get your views on
something else which is quite remarkable
this is these reports that uh illegal
immigrants regularly take ubers to
travel from the border to the
destinations within the united states
and we have a sound bite from an uber
driver about picking up illegal
immigrants just take a listen to this
we'll get a notification of a pickup
head down to the location and there will
be a group of 20 plus
immigrants standing on the corner
waiting for ubers and they'll just hop
in and
go wherever they're going
and this quickly is what the uh the
mayor said on illegal immigrants using
uber to travel from the border he said
this is new this is not something that
is a normal standard operating procedure
the mpp the migrant protection protocols
or the remaining mexico program coming
back online is correlated to roughly
where this happens i mean what do you
make of this are they so flippantly seem
to get in an uber across the border get
in an uber and be taken to their
destination inside the us
it's incredible the secretary of
homeland security still wants to say the
board is secure and it's close look in
my day this would never happen but
here's the problem there are so many
illegal aliens crossing the border
there's not enough mortgage relations to
apprehend them so last week in humidity
talking about yuma they had so many
people in detention it was overflowing
so they pulled all all the vortro agents
into process to relieve the overflowing
so there's hundreds of miles of border
unguarded not a single border to legend
and i had a board collision actually
sending me pictures of hundreds crossing
the line
unimpeded not being arrested not even
being talked about border patrol walking
to the city of yuma and they're calling
ubers this is the direct result of
biden's open policies where there's a
surge at the border that we've never
seen before let's remember this year
more illegal aliens crossed our border
than any time in the history of this
nation and they went to the most secure
border under president trump where
immigration was down at 35-year low and
turned around to be the most historic
illegal entry in the nation's history
within nine months on purpose
they intentionally get rid of the
policies at work this is open borders
and it's a free-for-all
yeah very quickly we don't have much
time but you've also said that border
patrol checkpoints have been shut down
the officers have been sent to the
border you say this is by design i mean
explain what the implications of that
are
look they've shut down into your
enforcement the most poor patrol
checkpoints are shut down so once you
get past the border you're home free and
ice has been decapitated the secretary
sent a memo a policy directive to ice
and it says this
being in the country illegally
is not enough to be arrested
so the cartels are using this to get
people across the board and get into
united states because they know there's
no consequence
well tom we hope this changes i know
you'll be here taking watching it for us
and keeping us up to date thank you sir
for your service and have a very merry
christmas sir thank you
merry christmas
i went on brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now